but nine-one-one
make sure she gets it Puka NATO I'm the
driver you called it a call me
girlfriend not a girlfriend man Oh
credit card was invalid give herself a
nice step I heard about these I've never
seen one before
yeah well that you have you're not gonna
ask me if she got home okay okay
I'm gonna need anything you might have
used to record what you did here tonight
get up you know a nice loser
my name is Amy give me a left hand it
was a Star Trek very good five stars for
Amy hey you should let somebody else do
this like Oh anybody you're right I
guess anybody could do it but nobody
does mile that's great you're helping
all these random people stay off the
radar
they killed my friend
so I'm gonna kill each and every one of
them the only disappointment is that I
only get to do it once it's mistake to
go to war with him they're highly
trained
they're gonna war with me you your
father your mommy just didn't tell you
on your stability if you're lucky
they'll give you the opportunity to do
the right thing
Hicks ain't one of those times
well 9-1-1 war you Jackie Chan
you